mon père est décédé d'un type de
cancer très
rare très soudainement.  Lives
nous a tous réunis
[Rires]
[Musique]
frère est mort
euh il n'avait que trois ans
J'étais juste sous le choc pendant un moment
J'ai hâte de vous connaître
et de commencer cette belle semaine
avec vous
tous  chaque campeur
dans votre téléphone chaque conseiller
qui est avec vous, nous sommes tous là pour
vous soutenir et nous voulons tous que vous passiez la
meilleure semaine de votre vie
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je vis dans la banlieue de Chicago et mon
sport préféré  est le patinage artistique euh mon
nom est hila je vis à New York ma
glace préférée est n'importe quoi de chocolat
et vous pouvez m'appeler Abby je suis de
Washington DC mon préféré mes deux
sports préférés sont le terrain de circulation et le
football à tout moment pour  comme si j'avais
besoin de parler à quelqu'un  ebody de toujours venir
vers l'un de nous et nous serons ici avec vous
24 7. si
étrangère
[Musique]
J'étais vraiment surprise et j'étais
comme d'accord mais
elle aime vraiment ça  Je
pense qu'elle a fait un très bon travail,
mais donc vraiment partager est peut
-être la partie la plus difficile ouais
parce que ça me donne envie de pleurer mais je
n'aime pas vraiment vouloir pleurer comme
devant tout le monde alors oui je sais
ça  chose pour la même chose mais
parfois c'est toujours difficile d'en
parler c'est aussi difficile pour toi comme tu
pourrais Je pourrais parler à un arbre et ça
pourrait être difficile pour moi l'arbre ne
me juge pas bien ouais parce que parfois
je le dis juste à haute voix  c'est dur
surtout avec ce qu'ils
te regardent tous comme si j'avais entendu ça
plus facile comme si j'étais comme si je
me parlais tout seul ou si je regardais en bas
ouais ouais j'ai l'impression que tu dois
beaucoup bouger ouais hé je '  j'y arrive
[Applaudissements]
ce sont de très belles photos que nous
aurons certainement  e tape parce que
tout le monde a de superbes photos
vous avez en quelque sorte le même sourire quand vous
souriez tout à l'heure vous voyez que vous avez
des styles similaires
êtes-vous prêt à partager votre histoire avec
moi ici ouais laissez-moi juste prendre une profonde
respiration d'
accord mesdames
euh ma mère  a été assassiné dans notre maison
c'était un meurtrier à louer alors quelqu'un a
embauché les hommes pour venir dans notre maison et l'
assassiner
mes ciseaux et c'est moi qui l'ai
trouvée ouais
mon père est décédé en 2016. c'était un
peu fou pour moi  parce qu'il était en si
bonne santé et il a eu une crise cardiaque à
l'improviste et c'était juste sorti de nulle part
je ne sais pas comment c'est vraiment arrivé
euh mon père est mort en 2013 d'un cancer quand
j'avais cinq ans c'était vraiment dur j'étais super
jeune donc je ne savais pas tout ce qui était génial
mais c'est ouais
euh
[Musique]
notre père il est mort par suicide
contrairement à d'autres décès comme des causes naturelles
comme euh une maladie ou quelque chose
tu sais que ça aurait pu être évité
et
euh c'est juste vraiment difficile de savoir ça
c'est tout
je pense que ça m'a donné comme un vrai  très mauvaise
anxiété j'ai eu la dépression que je fais toujours et
mes pensées comme me suicider comme des
pensées suicidaires
j'étais juste sous le choc pendant un moment j'étais
là à pleurer de nulle part oh la même
chose et surtout à l'école
parce que tout le monde serait comme parler
de leur père  et comme moi, mon père est au
paradis, donc je ne m'identifie pas vraiment à eux
quand les gens à l'école ne comprennent tout simplement pas
[Musique] les
gens ont dit que je mentais à propos de mon histoire
et cela m'a fait me sentir blessé
et j'ai eu l'impression que je pouvais '  Je ne leur parle pas
vraiment de tout ce que mon frère
ne rencontrera plus jamais son père
et ça me fait mal de
regarder ma mère et elle a de l'aide mais
parfois elle doit le faire seule
et ça me fait le plus mal
alors j'apprécie que vous preniez  cette
fois pour entrer à nouveau dans cet espace,
nous allons demander à JJ de poser leur question
comme toujours avant d'y entrer,
tout le monde va de l'avant et respire profondément
JJ ​​chaque fois que vous êtes prêt, d'accord, quelles
tactiques avez-vous déjà aimé apprendre à
respirer juste  être capable de trouver des personnes  ple avec qui
je peux faire confiance et me sentir en sécurité et
pouvoir te parler
et tout le monde que j'ai été L'Everest
était juste comme ça que je vais bien
[Musique] d'
accord si j'étais au plus bas j'étais comme
dévasté tout le temps je commencerais
pleurer au milieu de la classe en
sachant qu'elle est partie me fait vraiment mal mais à
chaque fois que je devenais triste, les gens
pensaient oh tu le fais juste pour
attirer l'attention
et
[Musique]
ça m'a rendu assez fou et puis
j'ai commencé à trouver de vrais amis
comme toi  les gars que j'ai aussi en quelque sorte
réprimés comme mes émotions
et tout le monde ici en tant que syndicat a
pu aimer partager leurs histoires, donc je me sentais à l'
aise de faire les miennes aussi et je
ne vais pas mentir un peu,
j'essaie toujours étonnamment d'oublier
mais je pense que c'est bien de
s'amuser parfois et d'essayer de l'oublier
mais parfois il faut le laisser sortir pour
que tout ne se produise pas d'un coup
ferme les yeux si tu te sens à l'aise
pense à un souhait que tu as pour
vous-même vous souhaitez que vous l'ayez pour vos
amis  e au camp ou n'importe qui à la
maison un deux trois
merci pour votre temps vous pouvez aller
vous amuser maintenant
c'est ce type d'environnement où
vous voudriez être vulnérable parce que
tout le monde ici est prêt à réconforter les
gens que
vous connaissez les normes sociétales qui aiment les
gars  qui attrapent vos émotions sont
censés être difficiles
[Music]
ça va se sentir vulnérable parce que
vous ne pouvez pas toujours être dans une coquille parfois
parfois vous devrez peut-être
sortir la tête comme une petite tortue
et ça ne va pas finir tout de suite toi '  Je
vais probablement être d'accord pour le reste de
ta vie, ça ne veut pas dire que ça doit être
si
difficile Je suis de retour mec oh mon Dieu allez je
continue de tomber c'est tellement malheureux
je dois dire que je ne me souviens pas
c'est comme ça bon
[Musique]
ton sourire brille sur moi
comme le soleil
et tes visages
Je me souviens comment le tien
[Musique]
et nous dansons toute la nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfois j'ai l'impression qu'il est juste
devant moi mais  Je ne peux pas vraiment le voir
ouais
comme je sais  ow qu'il est juste là mais
comme c'est bizarre parce que comme
il n'est pas là mais il est là
en même temps mais il est comme avec toi
ouais ouais
merci double The Barking pour le double
des cinq
ok
bien sûr parfois je pense toujours
mais le  des activités comme elles aident un
peu comme oublier tout et je
m'amuse tellement ouais
tu étais si proche depuis si longtemps
comment était-ce que tu as pleuré aujourd'hui non tu
n'as pas pleuré aujourd'hui ouais as-tu dit à tag
que tu  pleurer à chaque fois je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais ensuite quand je suis comme sur 1v1s
je vais bien quel était notre premier que nous
devions faire comme pourquoi nous étions ici ouais
à quel point notre père est décédé et puis
Zaya a commencé à pleurer
ouais ouais parce qu'il a perdu son père
soudainement aussi et vous savez et puis
m'a fait pleurer et puis j'ai partagé le décès de mon père
trop soudainement c'était l'année dernière
hé ouais horrible
C'est tellement connecté parce que je vous ai les
gars ouais ouais parce que pas beaucoup de gens
où  nous vivons comme si des tragédies se produisaient
ouais mais toi  comme tu ne sais jamais comment tu as
dit parce que c'est invisible pour toi ouais
comment ça fait quatre ans maintenant c'est toujours
pareil ouais je parie que ton cœur fait toujours mal
comment vas-tu c'est dur comme si tu
pensais à lui parfois et c'est
comme si tu ne pensais pas  c'est vrai ouais
s'il te manque ouais mon tour me manque
c'est juste incroyable de voir certains de ces
enfants grandir et s'ouvrir et parler de
certaines des luttes qu'ils ont eues
et puis j'ai en quelque sorte réalisé que je suis comme oh
mon  ça alors je n'étais pas seul tu as traversé
ça oh mon Dieu moi aussi et puis tu sais
être capable de créer cette corrélation donc dans
la culture américaine nous ne parlons pas de la
mort nous ne parlons pas du chagrin de mourir
c'est oh juste se sentir mieux nous  étaient si
gênants que nous ne savons pas quoi dire c'est
presque tabou c'est tellement ouais mourir est difficile
non et ça ne devrait pas l'être et entendre
quelqu'un qui a des années de plus que toi vient de
dire oui ma sœur est morte par suicide et
je suis très en colère  chez elle ou il y a des jours
où j'ai bonne mémoire en pensant
à ma personne un  Et donc ces
enfants de neuf ans sont capables de dire que
je suis en colère contre mon père et personne ici ne
va dire oh tu ne devrais pas être en colère,
il ne te manque pas et ils peuvent dire non
et c'est bon c'est l'un des  les
choses cool sur le deuil avec les enfants comme dans
ce cadre
je n'ai plus que deux notes à moins qu'Elle ne
veuille les faire mais je pense qu'elle
claque ouais quel est notre repos parce
qu'elle l'a raté
je beaucoup de gens pensent qu'ils ne sont pas
autorisés à être  heureux après avoir perdu quelqu'un
parce que parfois ils pensent que c'est de leur
faute parfois ils pensent qu'ils ont fait
quelque chose de mal ou quelque chose comme ça
mais vous pouvez réaliser que ce n'était pas de votre
faute c'est juste comme ça que la vie fonctionne et que
vous pouvez pleurer beaucoup plus facilement de cette façon
quand mon  papa était vivant il voulait vraiment un
jardin dans son dos dans la cour arrière alors
maintenant nous l'appelons notre arbre à papa que nous avons
récupéré de mes frères
c'est cool que vous ayez tous les deux des arbres comme
ça ouais mon père a été incinéré
quand il était vivant il a mangé beaucoup aussi  beaucoup
ouais c'est génial et donc toi
je sais que cela a rendu les cendres très collantes, d'
accord,
les choses dont vous ne parlez que ouais d'accord
euh le premier anniversaire de mon père après son
décès, donc dans le judaïsme, c'est réconfortant de
savoir que d'autres personnes ont vécu
ce que vous vivez quotidiennement et ils ont
fait leur  la vie heureuse après avoir
traversé tant de douleur
la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai aucun progrès
Je souffle mes frères et sœurs veulent tellement être comme moi
et parfois parfois je n'aime pas
ça mais d'autres fois c'est vraiment cool
de savoir que tu as  une bonne influence
sur vos frères et sœurs même s'il
m'a copié mais ça va
[Applaudissements]
ces gens que j'ai rencontrés
hier et ils ont déjà l'
impression que tout le monde ici est mon ami et
je peux leur parler
[Musique]
ma mère était une  personne très heureuse elle était
très attentionnée et ouverte d'esprit il était
toujours là sur les photos et avait toujours le
sourire les
gens disent toujours qu'il a comme son
visage et je l'ai moi-même
c'était une personne très spirituelle et amusante tous les
jours il le ferait  vivez comme si c'était sa dernière
nous vivons pleinement et en son honneur
[Applaudissements] d'
accord levez la main si vous avez appris
quelque chose sur vous-même cette semaine
levez la main si vous apprenez quelque chose
sur la façon dont les gens pleurent cette semaine
nous avons tous beaucoup de chagrin  différemment, mais à
travers notre expérience commune, il y a
beaucoup de similitudes
et c'est quelque chose qui nous rassemble tous
ici,
donc je vais demander à mon spécialiste du deuil
de venir et d'aider à distribuer
ces sacs décorez-le comme vous le
souhaitez peut-être que c'est le  le nom de votre personne
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui vous a poussé
hors de votre zone de confort cette semaine
ou quelque chose que vous avez appris sur
vous-même cette semaine
mon meilleur ami
étranger
les
gars étrangers Aaron est emballé en premier il gagne le
billet de cent dollars que
vous ne saviez pas  ça ouais
je ne voulais pas vraiment venir mais ensuite je
veux vraiment venir et je veux rester
mais ça m'a beaucoup aidé à rencontrer des
gens c'est tellement mieux
et j'aime comme ça alors tu te connais
Je ne suis pas seul, j'ai l'impression que lorsque vous soutenez
la personne, elle vous soutient toujours en retour
et je pense que c'est ce qui
me fait me sentir mieux dans ma
peau d'accord mon frère je les ai mis sur mon téléphone et je leur ai parlé
à peu près toute l'année d'accord
comment  tu me fais du bien bien ouais comment
ta semaine a été vraiment amusante ouais tu es
excité de rentrer à la maison
oui et non d'accord dis-moi pourquoi oui d'accord donc
je veux revoir comme ma mère et ma
nounou et tous mes amis mais je
vraiment  J'ai adoré le camp ouais je ne veux pas
partir qu'est-ce que tu aimes dans le camp Oh
tout le monde est vraiment très sympa J'ai
appris à aimer être plus ouvert parfois
avec mes amis et pas seulement ma
famille
étrangère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les souvenirs
me vont bien
[Applaudissements]